alors tu vires est compagne avec tes
animaux ou centaines de curieux padane
vient pas d'année des chevaux il n'y a
pas d'âme un jour une après midi je
pense que c'est à verneuil sur avre tu
rentres dans une église et tu découvre
comment s'est passée déjà découvertes
vardon c'est vrai ça ou c'est pas vrai
c'est totalement vrai ça s'est passé je
suis rentré dans une église parce que
j'avais envie de prier parce que j'étais
dans une période un peu difficile et ma
main gauche s'est mis à me brûler j'ai
dit à ma copine écoute tu es gentil mais
on va sortir parce que franchement cette
église de traîner face et c'est là où
j'ai découvert mon don de magnétisme
voilà et maintenant je soigne les amis
comme ça oui tu as découvert que tes
mains dégagé âme et roche lui d'amour
c'est vrai justement j'ai un peu là je
suis un peu le trapèze là un peu pour
nous et c'est l'habit de cheval que je
peux me faire quelque chose là n'ont
essayé je peux mettre ma main mais je
touche pas non mais même si tu veux
toucher je veux dire je te dirai ça
marchera pas c'est mon retour en france
après l'émission jean gaulin nos dents
dans la gorge à brut ou est ce que tu
crois que les gens savent ce que tu es
devenu c'est à dire les gens qui t'ont
vu non pas à l'époque dans des salles
itx parce qu'ils tombent surtout vu sur
canal dans sur les cassettes vidéo est
ce que tu crois que les gens aujourd hui
ça parce que tu es devenu ce que je suis
venu c'est à dire une personne qui vit
avec ses chevaux à 100 km de paris je
crois que maintenant les gens commencent
à quoi le savoir écoute on a envoyé
lendemain quand on va demander à laurent
baffie y que tu connais on lui a dit
cheikh rang tu vas aller dans la rue tu
as posé des questions genre se verra
demander si ça ce qu'il peut